[MUSIC PLAYING]
LISETTE TITRE-MONTGOMERY:
Hello, everyone.
So I'm the art manager
at Ubisoft San Francisco,
and I've been a game
developer for over 16 years.
So my journey to tech
is a little different.
I didn't start in
computer science,
but I was drawn to tech
through my love of art.
As a young child, I
was always drawing.
In fact, I used
to get in trouble
all the time for drawing in the
back of the Bible in church.
And I was always
looking for a medium
that I could find my
self-expression in.
So in high school I was taking
drawing, painting, photography,
pretty much anything I
could get my hands on.
But it wasn't until
I saw "Toy Story,"
and that's when it all clicked.
It was a mix of left
brain and right brain.
I was always a really
strong student.
However, I was always looking
for something a little bit more
challenging than
just traditional art.
Shortly after
seeing "Toy Story,"
I found my bachelor's program,
and I graduated with a degree
in computer animation.
And I quickly realized
that I was not
going to find the job
I wanted in Florida,
so I packed up my suitcases
and the workstation
I built by myself, and
I moved to California.
And I was very fortunate
that I got my first job
working in games.
So Freekstyle was
a motocross game.
And it is, essentially,
you are riding
on these very
over-the-top tracks,
and you're also trying to,
essentially, race other racers.
The big challenge with this
was it was my first game.
So my school training
trained me for film,
but it did not train
me for game engines.
So I had to really learn how to
get all of my art and content
into the game.
So that was a big
challenge, but I
think I really fell in love with
all the technical challenges
that were involved in it.
So I realized after
shipping Freekstyle,
that if I was going
to really make games
I needed to go the best
place to do it at the time.
And that was EA.
So I got hired as a
senior artist at EA,
and my first game
was Tiger Woods 2006.
It was also a launch
title for the PS3
and the 360, which means we kind
of knew what the specs were,
but we didn't have
final hardware.
And we had to figure all
this out in time to launch.
So a lot of the challenges
with Tiger Woods
was trying to figure
out how to get clothing
to animate without having
dynamic cloth simulation,
and also how to make realistic
African-American skin
and hair with all of the
new processing and power we
had with the new technology.
So I really focused on trying
to make Tiger Woods's skin
look great.
And I even went as far as
to go to the weave shop,
buy weaves and
braids, and scan them
in so that we had
accurate representation
of African-American hair.
After Tiger Woods
was the Simpsons.
So the big challenge
with the Simpsons
is that we were working
on a 2D show on a 3D game.
So we had a 3D open
world space and we
need it to feel like
the town of Springfield.
And we especially needed the
characters to stay on model.
So for example, Lisa,
that you see here,
she needed to look
exactly like she
would in the show at any
possible model, and any angle
that the camera could-- that
the user could set the camera.
So I literally
spent a [INAUDIBLE]
shaping Lisa's hair from
every possible camera angle
that the user could place it.
So it was a huge challenge,
but it was a very well-received
product.
So my next challenge
was Dante's Inferno.
And Dante's Inferno, just
like the classic story,
is based on hell.
So you're journeying through the
nine different circles of hell
through this game.
And working on this game
kind of felt like that.
[LAUGHTER]
This was the first time we
use distributed development.
So this was 2008 at the time.
So we didn't have Slack,
we didn't have Skype,
we didn't have video chatting.
It was me working with a
team in China over email,
and trying to tell a team of
artists what they needed to do
to get the game in the engine.
So it was a huge challenge.
And we were also trying to get
all this content in the game
with a smaller team.
So I had to learn how to do
lighting and special effects
and get all this
content in the game.
And it came out very well.
It was well-received.
And it was one of
the first games
to actually get a
Super Bowl commercial.
So after shipping
Dante's, I decided
I wanted to work at
a different studio,
so I went to Backbone
Entertainment.
And Backbone Entertainment had
a relationship with Harmonics.
And Harmonics develops
Dance Central 3.
So the big challenge
with Dance Central 3
was actually designing a game
for players who are in motion.
So you use the Kinect in
order to execute the moves
that you do onstage.
So while you're in
motion, you have
to figure out where
you are, whether you're
executing the moves
properly, and also
whether you are scoring up.
So we had to develop
technical ways and visual ways
to communicate to the player.
So something as simple
as a character's texture
on their clothing, if it was
too small, it would be blurry,
and it could literally make
a player miss the beat.
We also had to find ways to
communicate to the player
that they were doing well.
And we couldn't rely on
our usual techniques,
which is a small button at
the bottom or a health bar.
So we literally designed the
environments to give feedback.
So as you are doing well,
the world would light up,
and the whole scene would
function like an equalizer.
So we had to use very, very
unique design challenges
and use those techniques to
communicate to the player.
So my current challenge
is South Park.
I'm working on the next
sequel to South Park
called South Park, the
Fractured Butthole.
[LAUGHTER]
And our challenge
with this product
is actually eliciting
an involuntary response
from the player,
which is laughter.
How do you use game mechanics
to make someone laugh?
And that's our big
challenge for this product,
and we're having a
great time doing it.
So along my journey as a
developer over 16 years,
it's been very apparent to me
there are not enough people
of color in the industry.
And I was always a little
bewildered about this.
And it wasn't until I got the
cover of "Black Enterprise"
that I started to
understand the answer.
I got letters from
all over the country,
from parents and
children wanting
to know, my child loves games,
I want them to get interested
in technology.
How can I use this?
How can we leverage this?
To, I didn't think
black women made games.
I didn't think
that was possible.
So it became very
apparent to me that I
needed to start speaking
out about what I did.
So the first thing
I started doing
was going out and volunteering
and doing career conferences,
and also doing career
days at school.
So these are the students
from the Meadowood Livingston
school in San Francisco.
It's one of the only
African-American-focused
schools in San Francisco
that's publicly funded.
Shortly after that,
word got out that there
was a black female game
developer willing to speak,
and I started getting
contacted by nonprofits.
One of the first nonprofits
to reach out to me
was Black Girls Code.
And at the time,
Kimberly Bryant was just
a small after-school
program in the Bayview.
So I went out and I spoke, and
sort of shared my experiences
as a game developer,
and I still continue
to volunteer with
Black Girls Code.
They're actually
doing a hackathon
in the next few months
and they're really
looking for volunteers.
So shortly after
Black Girls Code,
I got contacted
by Youth Uprising.
Youth Uprising is a community
center in East Oakland,
and they provide a
safe space for students
to learn technology,
music, arts.
And the goal of
Youth Uprising was
for them to reach out to me and
my organization at the time,
Blacks In Gaming.
So I worked with Youth
Uprising on coming up
with an after-school program,
an eight-week program,
where we can train students
on game development
and coding skills.
And that program was recognized
by Governor Jerry Brown.
My current passion project
is Gameheads Oakland.
So Gameheads Oakland was
founded by Damon Packwood.
He actually just won an
Echoing Green fellowship
for the program that
we're working on.
And we volunteer and work
with students 15 to 24
on game development
skills and coding skills.
One of the great things
about this program
is that I tap my network
of game developers
and we bring them in
and provide mentorship
to every single student, and
this entire program is free.
We're also looking
for volunteers.
[APPLAUSE]
So I was very honored to be
invited to the White House
this August to participate
in an LGBTQ program.
And what we were doing
was brainstorming
on solutions and technology
to improve inclusivity
in tech hiring.
So I was honored to meet
Megan Smith, the former CTO
of the United States.
And we were able to spend
a day in the White House
and really think about ways we
can make tech more inclusive.
So if you want to know
more about what I do,
you can reach me at my
website lisettetitre.com.
and you can also find me on
Twitter at zette16@gmail.com,
and please reach
out to the orgs,
and the many orgs you'll
hear about today, with some
of your time in volunteering.
Those organizations really need
your technology experience.
And just seeing more
women and women of color
will let the next generation
know what is possible.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]